hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play gray all
right we got that rum over there that's
kind of smoking well how are you Oh
probably not a good idea to go in there
but here we go oh okay
Oh oh no I gotta fess up okay nevermind
yeah perfectly fine not a problem Blanc
is locked I can't open it again
god dammit does that guy just pop up out
of nowhere random times man Oh goose
bumps
give your pain a rest give you some pain
[Music]
step into the ball mill Oh No
[Applause]
[Music]
oh ho ho I don't like that music oh it's
a bad idea to go in there ah not scary
not scary what are you box you chain
yeah what are you what are you all okay
any semblance of logical reason had
fallen away I had become lost within
this place seemingly cut loose from any
landmarks of reality the horrors I see
appear to me as memories acts of
unspeakable cruelty and evil long since
committed but as yet unpunished okay
baby where's the two babies why Oh
what it's a freaking baby oh that's not
a baby what is going on
ah why are you eating that knife that's
bad stop it oh my oh my this is getting
just a little freaky wat da
Hey
knives that's a fork that's a knife as
schizos oh oh oh
[Music]
nope nope I want to go back to
semblances resemblances of reality
please thank you
oh is that a battery for my drill thank
you thank you so much
shouts gun I got a shotgun now Oh screw
that
that's that bad ha that's not a room for
me I belong in a finish the person
okay all right hey there buddy nice bed
you got here
ah well their faces I thought they were
like oh god the flash their faces I
thought they were like sleeping bags or
body bags or something their faces oh my
oh my goodness
hey there lady guy no no can't tell oh
my oh my goodness I didn't ask for this
care about myself and others wait a
minute it's slender Elementary okay it
was not an accident
[Applause]
if I could have just want them out no ow
frak hello miss doop do perfectly normal
just a head you know being there the
bullets is in this I should huh
oh no I'm assembling her Oh
oh hello ladies I think ladies I'm not
sure exactly okay no way back I could go
back I don't think it wants me to go
that way they seem like they could have
been friends
I could have had a friend oh this is
impossible
he's beyond impossible Oh what is that
oh that what was that what was that what
was that who's out there who's out there
is the Big O Marky no likey
there wasn't anything over here this is
a waste of time
oh it was so bad I'm gonna die oh he's
so bad I don't think I should have went
that way I think that was a bad way
to go fooling around
oh why okay don't go that one way good
thing I don't think I saved since then
so oh god oh it's so bad okay
no doggy's no no doggy's no i shouldn't
have wasted all those shells on those
babies I shouldn't have wasted so much
ammo shooting those babies that's
something I never thought I'd say ever
in my life Wow right there I still gotta
get through that last one with no ammo
ah what's out there
occupied by me the things I do for you
guys the things I do for something
happened to the forest yesterday I heard
some kids amongst the trees screaming
running kids running amongst the trees
screaming a few minutes later some
adults carried an injured girl into the
old house I didn't want to go in so I
just looked in through the hole behind
the wooden sheep but a little girl
blocked the view then I heard an
ambulance so I went back to my house
terribly excited man
please do tell about how great that
story was
I'm just not uh there's no way I can't
possible something is blocking the door
from the other side so my bad
getting somehow maybe no no no no no no
no no no no man getting the head was
easy why is this so much more
complicated nope okay that's obviously
not working oh well how about this
obviously Oh
yeah boom Oh
makeshift weapons are my baby boom can I
get these the other way no nevermind
whatevs I would rather have ammo and
health but whatever I'm gonna make do
yeah oh yeah Kade you're freaking schoen
so badass please be a health box
please be a health bar somewhere the leg
oh okay okay I got no health but I got a
sledgehammer concrete thing Oh
what da chair what are you doing up
there keeping an eye out for me good
that time he did something useful
[Music]
I don't want I literally have nothing
else I don't have a met kid I'm gonna
die so easily
Oh what is that it's a raining blood is
it raining blood it's raining blood here
I go
Oh numbers birdie [ __ ] it man I need to
get home
I'm guessing this as a puzzle of sorts
let's try yes this could be trial by air
okie dokie Jake do you know how else am
I supposed to do this besides just
random chance there must be a numbered
order ok seven-30 loser ok I don't think
I got anything that clued in to numbers
300 failure all right anyway I'm all out
of time so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye-bye